when i talk up when i think about kabir
norma gomanov
i see all the detail that that of his
work especially when he got he's got his
opponent against defense that's
like that's his area of expertise
worries to me he's the
best that ever did it in in terms of
that fighting style that that particular
expertise that he has it's just the the
flawless execution of that particular
set of techniques
yes conor mcgregor had the
the accuracy the spider anderson silver
was like was i would say the most
flamboyant of all you know like he was
moving like the matrix
john jones was incredible in terms of
creativity
spinning elbows and that and he faced an
incredible
adversity dmitry was johnson was
so complete you could you could bring
like he was slamming a guy to an armbar
it was just unbelievable like like
he was like the complete fighter
bj penn was like so flexible he he did
stuff with his body then
like nobody could do his dick the
dexterity of his hips was just
unbelievable
um dominic cruz to me was incredible his
footwork his distance control
so when you talk about like the goat
royce gracie another one
he did things that i think for me is not
number one because yeah i gotta i gotta
and starting to interrupt the hoist is a
fascinating one
i'd love to hear what you think about
them but many people
consider you most people consider
you to be the number one greatest
mixed martial arts fighter ever so it's
fascinating to
remove you from that list and continue
this discussion
and asking like who do you think is the
greatest fighter ever you listed some
amazing ones
hois you somehow skipped fedora it's as
i'm very as a russian i'm very offended
no
i was going to there's so many fedoras
one as well
fedora i think in his prime was like
when you say when you talk about
a name for example like
we talked about him when he was in his
prime like when i talked for example
about anderson silva i'm not talking
about the andersons of who
fought his last fight uh against uraya
hall i'm talking about anderson servo
who knocked out
victor belfor yes bg pen same thing
the problem is when fighters hang on for
too long in the sport that's what
happened
they kind of make make
people forget how good they were and
it's very sad we talk about fedor and
just
just think about uh stephen yochich
me which is probably the greatest
heavyweight of all time with fedor
i would really wonder who would have won
this fight the both guys in their prime
i tend to lean towards fedor because my
heart was with fever the fedor but he
could have gone the other way but just
because meow chich
lose his last fight now everybody's like
oh yeah they forgot about him
it's crazy man it's one fight you zig
when you shoot zag
boom it's that's the reality of mixed
martial art well that's why
the thing is the mixed martial arts
isn't just
the performance the strictly who won and
who lost it's also the stories we tell
ourselves
and so i mean there's beautiful stories
being weaved
and that also is part of uh who is the
greatest of all time
is what what were the battles what
what had to be overcome what was the
the flavor of the flawless performances
you know all of that plays into it and
you're right
being able to walk away at the top is
also part of that
you